hey kkk are you a fan of cultural
appropriation
of course i can't go down to the local
supermarket unless i'm dressed like a
mexican bandit
or as i like to think about it your
cousin in that case you're going to love
beer rebel noodles
they make award-winning delicious ramen
noodles with an irish twist
for bankruptcy and alcoholism no all
their noodles are homemade using high
quality ingredients
in fact respected food critic jay raynor
called them deserving of poetry what a
cuck
man up jay their sauces noodles and
broths are created using skills
that were developed over years of
working in michelin-starred kitchens
they're dead easy to make the noodles
take one minute to cook
and the whole dish takes only 10 minutes
to put together
in the comfort of your own home i'm
hungry just explaining this to you
you're always hungry mate i mean that's
a fair point go to beerble.com
that's b i a r e b
e l dot com and get a tasty flavor of
the east
in your dinner time yet again yet
another election
where in some cause and i'm not saying
this is true it's definitely not many
people in the labour party and generally
on the left are saying this but there's
certainly people on the center left
there's standard reaction to losing yet
another
election is why won't these gullible
[ __ ] vote for us
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster
i'm constantine kitten and this is a
show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people we do have a
fascinating guess for you today but just
to set the context we're recording this
the day
after the local elections in the uk
where the conservative party which has
been in power for 11 years
has actually advanced and made more
progress particularly by capturing the
working-class vote so we thought
who better to get back on the show than
our regular one of our favorite guests
he's a comedian jeff norcop
hello welcome back mate yeah i mean i
was thinking when i was on this before
it feels like i've been saying the same
thing about what's likely to happen
for quite a while there's a few people
have been saying this about the
working-class vote
it's not an unfamiliar narrative and
then and here we are there was this
iceberg
that the labour party were warned about
and they said no no we just
keep [ __ ] sailing towards that i
think we could sort of chicane around
that iceberg i think iceberg would be
okay and
it's interesting you know like in terms
of normally i like good politics
right you know the idea of an opposition
and
it's all sort of funny when labor do
badly i can't explain exactly why that
is
i think i think we know it's sort of
funny and yet i don't know man as this
is happening i i find myself slightly
melancholic for the state of the
opposition you know because it's it's
quite sad in a way
you know i think when i love and when
england play australia
you want to beat australia but i mean
there was a period when we were
battering them at home
that's not as much fun and it's also not
good for cricket and i think there's
probably something
true about that in politics as well well
the thing with you is you didn't always
vote tory right you only started voting
tori about 2010.
yeah uh and you've written a book which
is called where i went right which is
about your journey how the left lost me
yeah yeah which is which they would call
victim blaming
yeah yeah but yeah i mean the timing
this kind of comes out on the thursday
the 13th of may i mean and all anybody's
talking about at the moment
is about the migration of working-class
voters away from the labour party
interestingly you know the way that the
pandemics gone there were times last
year because we finished the manuscript
and you know i filed it in november and
i was like jesus like this is gonna look
ridiculous everyone's gonna deserve the
tories if
if the management of the pandemic is as
shambolic as it's been so far
and then now it probably goes the other
way you know where
where if anything i might have slightly
underestimated things
and you i mean we are where we are why
do you think it is
that the working classes particularly up
north have turned their back on labor
well i suppose you know there's so many
reasons aren't there
there's so many we just pick a hot topic
jeff's not excited about this at all
yeah it's very sad no i am not a kid
well
what i thought was about my own process
of voting on this occasion let's bring
it
right down to the ballot box what
happens when you go there and people
might not think
that i do this but i always ask myself
last minute questions about okay
could i vote for the other lot you know
when even when it was leave
when it was the brexit referendum my
choice was between leave and abstain
right
and i always ask myself that question
you know even in the 2019 general
election there was
aspects of the tory campaign which i
wasn't fond of and again i asked myself
that question on this occasion
okay they've been things i haven't liked
about the toys uh over the last year
so let's just go through the other
options i went could i vote
no i can't vote i just it's a million a
million reasons why not
jeff why can't you vote labour the offer
i think it's the overall offer isn't it
of the left
is not a good offer what what do you
mean by the offer
it's not just the labour party as well
where the the image the perception
of the left that's often what people are
partially voting for in their mind
i i put an x here what do i get it's not
just about the labour party you know
it's something
beyond that what am i endorsing and
there's you know there's
a culture uh within and without the
labour party that is way left of the
country
you know in terms of you look at their
activists and their membership base and
where the country's at
and what the country thinks of
priorities who wants to tear down
statues who wants to get on with things
right now you look at even corporate
culture
you know a lot of these companies are
trying to send out appealing messages uh
you know i don't know who they always
think that they're appealing to but
they they seem to think that young
people are the only people that buy
stuff
and the young people won't get more
right wing as they get older that's
always quite an interesting
misguided supposition there's just this
there's
there's so much there's so much there's
the current leader kirsten i don't think
he's a bad guy i don't he's a bad
politician but he doesn't
he doesn't he doesn't summon anything in
me you know like
and people want to feel something from a
leader people want to feel
so not inspired but they want to feel
moved and when he came into power when
he became leader there was a lot of talk
about forensic here and that was
touted in social media to be a good
thing and you know it's a good thing
when you're a qc
to be forensic but if you're
look this is a very base analogy but if
you're on a stag do
and you've got forensic here and rugby
tackle boris
who you and and the knight splits up a
bit or we'll go in different places yeah
where are you going you know and and i
think that people want to
people like boys people i'd say this the
country like boris a lot more than i do
i'm not yeah wouldn't close but i was
going to say that you talk about making
a leader making you feel something
i mean i'm going on on the stag dude i'm
going out with boris yeah yeah the
following day i'm like oh mate i've got
to get an earlier train
i mean i'm not necessarily wanting to
hang out with a bloke but he makes
people feel something and then you've
got
what was what the labour doc labour
party done we've had these existential
crisis in terms of
brexit and covid and it does seem that
in both instances their their
uh strategy was this was a tricky one
for the tories they're in a bit of a
mess let's just
let's just see how this plays out
they've done that for both things and
this is this is within
you know within the space of two and a
half years we've seen them do this
they've pre-barricaded
and they've essentially sort of hoped
that there was
a coach crash right they've seen the
coach veering off the motorway and
they've gone the most important thing
for us to do is that there's no footage
of us with our hand on the wheel
that is that is cowardly in a way and
and yeah the the mps the parliamentary
labour party to an extent
they just don't feel connected
they don't seem to see the world the
same way that i do and
another thing to just remember is that
you know in the very recent past
the tories have grappled with difficult
things and got results right so whether
brexit
completely um unfails and this deal was
proved to have been shoddy
at this point they they did it you know
they actually did deliver something and
in western democracies
for a long time no one's done anything
radical right he actually you know
and and the left are probably their own
worst enemies in that they've made it
possible for boris johnson to look like
[ __ ] he-man
for doing things that weren't that
impossible
you know so we'll never get he'll never
get the withdrawal agreement open he did
that right never get a trade deal
within a year he got that right never be
prime minister never win an election
he'll never turn kovid round and he's
done all these things and and he ends up
sort of but i didn't get more credit
perhaps
than he deserves for for these things i
mean even as i'm talking now i'm
bouncing around things because there
were
there are so many different reasons i
mean the economic news
that's come out in the last few days the
that once again the most dystopian
prophecies
of parts of the left about what's going
to happen to this country
have underestimated how dynamic and
vibrant the economy is
do you think that's it jeff like
everything now and it's not just the
left it's also people on the right like
we catastrophize everything so much and
maybe it's just so common now to be like
well
you know brexit will never happen or if
it does it will be the end of the
and that's because they're trying to
stop it happening and in
in when they go over the top but that's
my point right it's like
they go so far because they think that
if they say you're going to get super
gonorrhea and there'll be no sandwiches
left like
that will stop brexit that was the most
two most powerful arguments for me that
was the only time
hang on no sandwiches yeah i got a flaky
dick
i yeah they they they slightly over
again a lot
right and we're all kind of in that in
that loop of like the media exaggeration
the twitter hyperbole
yeah but then there's a price to pay for
that down the line when
when the public go actually what none of
that has happened so you've been
bullshitting the whole time
why would we take you seriously now no
absolutely and large swathes of uh the
sort of center-left media commentary
have sort of fired all their bullets
they've spurned their credibility
one in in respect of how dystopian their
predictions about brexit were
and two you know some of the attacks on
on boris there are certain things that
were absolutely legitimate
but there have been times within the
last year where he does
he does something odd to intelligent
people he makes them a bit deranged
they hate him they hate him so much like
we just got if i could just get
boris out of power something would be
clean something would be okay
with the world again and i think the
public see that sometimes you know
whether it's a
an opening homily or a monologue on news
night or or it's it's
certain stories being fanned slightly
beyond
uh their actual relevance to a lot of
people i mean the most recent one is is
curtin gate you know
i think it was fair for kia stammer to
ask those questions at pmq's maybe not
as many as he did but i think he was
you know he has to bring stuff up that
like that up and then like the following
day
he's in john lewis and he's looking at
wallpaper and
like and on social media that gets a lot
of credit they're like oh oh sick burn
care you think yeah it just made him
look fixated
yeah made him look fixated on a
triviality and you at a time where
there's there's a pandemic you know we
need to rebuild the economy
you've got what's happening in india
first you get six questions at pmq's and
he did three
on curtains but don't you think a large
part of the problem is
that people in london who are very
middle class don't understand working
class people yeah they don't really talk
to them they don't really encounter them
they don't know what it's like to live
in a town like rotherham or the rest of
it
so how can they how can they represent
them
well i mean we've seen yet again yet
another election
where in some causes and i'm not saying
this is true it's definitely not many
people in the labour party and generally
on the left are saying this but there's
certainly people on the center left
there
their standard reaction to losing yet
another
election is why won't these gullible
[ __ ] vote for us
i mean these stupid people once again
self-harm they've been duped i'd say you
know what if they're that easily duped
why can't you do them
right a lot of politics is about
propaganda it's about
fluffing an idea every party to varying
degrees is selling something beyond
which
something way bigger i mean this
leveling up thing right it's fantastic
it makes me feel good i'm not sure
how much of it they'll be able to do but
that's a job of politics to sell
something hopeful and something positive
and
so that's the labor party's job is to do
the same thing but they can't
dupe anybody at the moment and also i
mean the nhs is a good point in a way
there some of the old certainties about
politics have been shattered but you
know i
know a lot of left-wing friends have
said to me and this is a classic
anecdote isn't it when i've got a point
i want to make it's like actually i was
speaking on the doorstep of someone
convenient who are made up but um but
genuinely a lot of left-wing friends
have said to me that the
the furlough scheme really surprised
them you know the way they'd been
conditioned their whole lives
it certainly wasn't that the tories
would swoop in and pay people's wages
and the original furlough was
probably more generous than it needed to
be and i think the fact that the country
of accrued 150 billion quids worth of
savings suggests that they might have
not got the balance quite right there
and then the nhs as well you know
you can make a really legit argument
about whether or not the nhs was funded
enough going into this pandemic
but the truth is it's been prioritized
within the context of it and a lot of
right-wing people
would say that it's been too prioritized
it's been too protected so these are
two old certainties right of british
politics the tory party they they don't
care about you they won't spend money
they spent money right with the nhs they
want to destroy it and for the last 15
years every single election it's the
most obvious one in the playbook is
the nhs it's minutes from from death
is this the end for the caped crusader
it's almost like those old batman adam
west is it is it the end
of course it's [ __ ] not he's got
another episode next week
and the nhs i mean the nhs it would be
the the quickest suicide note in
political history would be
to to end the principle of uh health
care that's free at the point of
services
conservative party have never will never
do that okay
what they will have now is this i think
amusing challenge in a way is they've
got this new
broad coalition of voters and i fully
expect them to become a lot more
northern i look they've done a bit of it
maybe they'll risk you with the
yorkshire team but yeah
they are going to lean into this you
know they're going to lean into this
hard
and some of the things that they've done
it just people sold their performative
gestures right
um like moving treasury offices to york
okay it is a symbolic gesture but labour
could have done that symbolic gesture
you know had a long time in power they
could have done it it's just good
politics right
so i and also york is posh
york is the one place they go to yeah
they get a nice train journey up there
on the east coast main line have a
little bit of lunch up there
arrive half cut yeah i mean i mean
they're not doing in wakefield
let's put it that way but like this is
this is common sense to to spread
the power base uh around the country and
and i'm not i'm not saying it this is
weird because
i probably was as uncertain about voting
conservative in this last election
as i have been for a while and yet it's
really
not hard to work out why why they've
done well
let's talk about your journey actually
just i just wanted to make this one
question all right
so they're in the ship right labour we
all know that
okay please don't show this diet coke
we've got sponsors jeff come on
it's okay i made it at home
[Laughter]
it's your home brew my own recipe yeah
yeah why do you think you're so happy
because it's fueled with something right
but so we've got the labour party
how do they turn it around then how do
they capture the ordinary bloke on the
street
they can't i don't know i don't think
that they can and i know look at his
face
i just i don't i feel a bit bad for them
in a way because this isn't
just about things that the labour party
have done by them yeah
this has been other factors that are
partially beyond their control
i mean they were egged on to a position
of second referendum by
a london-centric media i don't know this
is how everyone feels
you know lynn at hot yoga we we all
think that there should be
a second referendum they were egged on
weren't they by kia starman no no no
we've got we've got an e-petition well
you know a lot of the gmail addresses
sound [ __ ] similar but we've got this
six
million person petition to revoke the
referendum so they
they were egged on in that and let's
just just quickly briefly stopping that
before i go back to your question
within the last year and a half the
labour party right the club the party of
the working classes
voted or moved to a position a farcical
position whereby
they did not respect the democratic
outcome now i know at that point
there were a lot of issues with getting
brexit delivered but their job like when
when you vote that is the only time you
have true equality in this country right
whether you're jacob rees-mogg
or whether you're in brian cox weird
reference point but you know what i mean
like they probably are the other ends of
the culture
they're supposed to protect that and
they didn't protect that and that if you
think about how long it took the lib
dems to get past tuition fees this is
way [ __ ] um beyond that and then
another fact of francis is you've got
like this migration
of people out of those towns like a lot
of people youngsters are going to
metropolitan centers like newcastle
or manchester or london or bristol but
it kind of leaves
these towns vacant of people that might
vote labour
and i said on my podcast at the
beginning of this year i said
one of my boldest predictions was that
the labour party might formally split
and you always think well
they look into the abyss and then they
they reunite but it feels more
fundamental this time and i don't
honestly know how the two wings of the
labour party uh can reconcile
it's something we've been talking about
on this show quite a lot and i just want
to
people may be watching for the first
time or not familiar with our views like
francis and i are not happy about what's
happening we
you know him and i both used to vote
labor frequently uh
lib dem as well in my sir i apologize
but like i've been there like we all
have you know
right we all did crazy stuff yeah
exactly
so but you know what i mean like i don't
think it's a healthy position
at all where you've got a party that's
in power for 11 years
and it's doing better and better and
opposition is worse and worse
and i think your point about the media
in particular is very true where
and doing the show has actually shown me
that to a large extent there's a whole
body of people particularly
outside the big cities and particularly
outside of london who just don't they
don't feel represented by anything they
see on their screens
that's that's mainstream and the labour
party is pandering to that as opposed to
actually trying to connect with people
but for anyone who's not familiar with
you i want to talk a little bit about
your background because you talk about
it in the book
when right you talk about growing up uh
tell everybody a little bit about your
back story your background
like what was your childhood like and
because that informs a lot of your views
i think and that's what i always found
interesting about you well
i mean like inherently i should be labor
you know a lot of people think the
southeast but as you all know there's
there's a strong working-class tradition
and and labor
labor trade union movement in the
southeast as well despite
perceptions my dad was a trade union man
you know my mum both my parents were
disabled
lived on council estates and council
properties so i was kind of had a lot of
the
the sort of ticklish eventually you know
went into comedy but you know that
in a way is the point of the book where
did i go right right like
everyone always says well how does
someone like you end up voting for the
so-called
baddies but then it go you know it turns
out now you're asking that question of a
lot of people right that is now no
longer
um an uncommon thing and i think the
truth is is that i voted labour in 97
2001 and stuff initially it was just a
ubiquitous
yeah you know we all did then brit pop i
was in london i thought everybody voted
later i just thought it's what you
i just thought this is what you do right
um but if i look deeper into my
childhood i can actually see that they
were at least small c conservative
things you know
i got a bit stick for this because of an
article in a mail on sunday
but i do i can remember one of my first
memories not one of my first memories
but
an early memory of just people on
wearing dressing gowns off
like all day long you know on this day i
[ __ ] can't handle
i might get dressed you know that's
quite just quite a judgy little
conservative
reaction isn't it like for god's sake
get dressed what are you doing i've just
got this fear that you know you
shouldn't wear a dressing gown after
9 00 a.m unless you're ill or hugh
hefner only two
contacts right and and i remember
getting free school meals
and not not liking that and hating that
and just
wondering you know i was told that well
the state paid for it i was like who's
the state
what if they decide they don't want to
pay for it i can remember like the
anxiety
of being not poor this gets overstated
you know people want me to
sort of hype this up we weren't but we
had periods where it was really close to
the breadline but overall
in the context of where we lived we did
okay but i remember those moments
because we started off doing all right
my family we were you know we had a
private property in a decent street in
wimbledon but then the family got
my mom and dad got divorced and then we
moved to a council estate so
that's quite an interesting status drop
at the age of nine so it might have
heightened
my sensitivity to it and we used to get
like clothing
grants and stuff like that and i was
dressed like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i remember once i remember once i had
these these trousers that were so tight
i went to school in wandsworth and as
you remember
cussing people oh yeah just like an
olympic sport you know best mates being
as mean to you as possible
i had these skin tight trousers before
they were fashionable
and one of that said to me he went my
god jeffrey goes i can see your pulse
which is a put down i still use to this
day yes so i guess there was a material
thing in me
quite early was i just wanted more and a
lot of people in this country just want
that right yeah just i want to do all
right i want to do right for myself
this is the most human thing imaginable
is to want to do okay for yourself and
improve the situation your family
and beyond that improve society as a
whole for a lot of people those are the
sort of stages of priority that you go
through
and yet there are there have been times
certain this is not just from the labor
party but
the left that that kind of aspiration
has seemed like
in some ways a dirty thing and and i
read an article in the times this
morning
by janice turner i think was saying that
just a lot of people don't have the same
sad drab lives that the labour party
think they have
you know in hartlepool yes salaries are
a lot lower
but so houses so there's a lot of things
a lot of people in hartlepool
are having the things materially in life
that a lot of us
are looking for and and this period
particularly under corbyn whereby
everyone was painted to be a victim
there's a lot of working-class people
don't want to be thought of as having
[ __ ] lives right there are definitely
there's people
in society that are really struggling
and i think that you know you should
definitely focus more resources on those
people
outside of that if you've got a gaff car
a couple of holidays a year a couple of
nights out a month
it's a good life but it's the thing as
well it's like i think people massively
misunderstand i just from my experience
and i
i talking in russia there's
working-class people in russia as well
like in many different places
people don't want free stuff really most
people don't most people don't want free
stuff they don't want
free internet access they want a job and
they want to work and they want to
do well you know they're not looking to
get loads of handouts now
if you say that's where they went wrong
in russia in the end i would say that
would definitely be the worst country to
have communism there
yeah we don't actually want frisbee yeah
terrible accidents
where was that it was i anywhere in
eastern europe yeah yeah i think you
were in serbia mate
probably the most racist country in
europe come on
it was it was the really liberal bit of
serbia yeah you know what pisses me off
people people say that my russian accent
is worse than
many other comedians i'm actually
russian yeah we all try and then we all
still say well where was i croatia
yeah i don't know where no but you know
what i mean like i think yeah if you ask
people
are you in favor of free internet a lot
of people will say yeah but
in general they're not in favor of the
state yeah providing a ton of free stuff
for people because
they they they have to work for a living
and it's kind of like
ingrained in people without loss of
responsibility for your own stuff right
you might get a free ticket to go and
see a great band
at the o2 or whatever and you will enjoy
that night but i'll tell you something
the ticket that you paid for when
that you sat and the day it was coming
out 9am they go on sale and you sat i
was gonna say on the phone make it
myself
okay boomer right i was sat there i was
looking on c facts
until the youtube tickets come up but
you did yourself you could enjoy more
it's got a sweeter
feeling to it and i do worry that over
the years and this is under successive
governments and also
a lot under the conservatives they've
got a lot of these patrician
elements themselves it's just bit by bit
taking stuff out of people's
control i just worry that if you remove
those things from the human character
you stop evolving in a way it's a really
important thing
taking responsibility for your own [ __ ]
it's an empowering narrative
because the good thing about it is that
you have capacity to change it yourself
if you sort of abdicate responsibility
you're powerless
i have to believe that i can make stuff
better for myself
sometimes to a deluded fault you know
but all the time
you spend thinking other people have
kind of taken away opportunities from
you
it's time that you could be spent um
pursuing them yourself obviously
there's certain elements of social
justice that need to be pursued but in
terms of getting
[ __ ] done in your own life that's mainly
what you'd have to focus on
and the thing that i was very very
surprised by
and i i didn't predict in the slightest
was this
new authoritarianism creeping into the
left particularly when it comes to
coving
oh we've got a lot i think the zara
sultana so we've got to lock down
everything
until you know there's not one covered
case left are you nuts i mean there are
certain incantations
on the left that really worried me and i
think that no one's safe till everyone's
safe
first off no if you can imagine someone
doing that as they say it's probably
bollocks
yeah no one's safe today that's not just
[ __ ] not true yeah
it's not true of anything no one's drunk
till everyone's drunk that's not true
yeah
okay no one say to everyone self safe
sounds like the kind of thing that jason
staven would say
just before he hops out of a [ __ ]
chinook yeah okay no one's safe till
everyone said what's that jason that's
not even logically possible
yeah and and i think the problem with
those kind of incantations
is the purpose of them is not for other
people it's because it
makes you feel good as you say and if
you're saying or doing something because
it makes you feel good
rather than because it makes a change
for the people that need it that's
selfishness
that's the opposite of what the left
purport to be and you know the blair
project to new labor was about the left
kind of reigning in certain instincts
because they knew that the only way that
you could really make a change for
people was to have
the levers of power whereby there are
some elements of the model left
for them principled opposition seems to
be
a more important thing than abs than
actually being in power which i'd argue
weirdly is narcissistic
francis do you like biscuits stupid
question
if you like biscuits as much as him you
have to try
zingy berry bakery they're a small
family-run bakery that make
award-winning sweet cookies and savory
crackers
francis will explain how many awards
they want weren't you francis
the sumptuous cookies are made with
whole grain oats and real butter while
their savory crackers are made with
whole grain oats
and are both wheat and dairy free
they've got a brilliant offer
all you have to do is enter our code
which is of course triggered
on your first order and you'll not only
get 10 off
they'll give you free delivery as well
that's 10 off and free delivery on your
first order with our code which is
triggered
go to zingerberrybakery.co.uk the link
is in the description
it's zingerberrybakery.co.uk and get
your biscuits today
i think i've eaten too many biscuits
never heard him say that before
wow but i mean
again like the point that we always have
to ask ourselves is where do we go from
here
because the reality is things are
it seems desperate don't you don't
you're right mate yeah
i'm not going to look at yourself he's
sad
in three different parts of britain yeah
yeah right it's not great
no no it's not it's not great smp labor
got
uh uh white wales yeah great the big
one yep and you know uh the one place
that can actually win you a majority in
parliament which is england
is is run by the toys it isn't fantastic
but is it maybe a
a degree to which we've all retreated
into identities yeah
people who are taurian are mortory
aren't they you know i i do worry about
this as well so something that the left
certain people on the left on the online
hard left have done is every time
there's a vote and every time you get
called selfish or
stupid they sort of radicalize tories
people that [ __ ] tori for the first
time
i think oh yeah just on this occasion
i'll lend boris my vote or or or maybe
i'll vote cameron this time because i
think that you know after the credit
crunch labor had spent a lot maybe
oh i'm a [ __ ] ignorant selfish
it's like you know like certain things
the the us did in the middle east
radicalized
radical islamists i think you've got
people that are way more tory now than
they would have otherwise been
and of course it goes the other ways and
you know i have noticed
on the online right there's an element
of kind of intellectual certainty that's
creeping in and those people on the left
are never going to come over if they've
been called certain names as well
but i just think that if you look across
a 10-year period
that was a phenomenon it certainly
seemed to start on the left and you go
great that person is probably going to
vote tory for the next
three elections it is weird do you know
like my old man he was in the labor
party i am
there's i am sort of sad about what's
happening and that might sound
melee mouthed but i wanted to be like
yeah you know the old thing but
i don't know something happened for me
after that 2019 general election i'm not
as tribal as i was i started you know
this culture war thing
it's a bit ridiculous sometimes and it
pulls you into points of view that you
wouldn't have otherwise had you got i
don't know why i'm just angry about
meghan markle i don't know
i just don't care that much you know so
there are certain issues whereby you go
no
so i'm trying to to just stop and think
what do i think exactly
and i think we've had this chat before
constantine actually the more precise
about what you think
the more that you piss people off right
yeah so i did a radio 4 special recently
and there was a section in the middle
of it about black lives matter and of
course you know i critiqued some of the
hypocrisies about how people responded
to the mass gatherings
and also about uh certain political
motives on the groups
uh but also after a couple of weeks of
black lives matter
it did make me stop and reflect about
the experience of you know black people
in this country and
the message that i had in that bit was
probably one that would be seen as quite
liberal
and left wing and of course i had like
twice coming for me on facebook
you know direct messages i always get
the cowards on direct messages and then
are you sold out to the libs and stuff
going
the idea that like the consequence of a
culture war would just own
every single opinion i have is
ridiculous yeah but the danger is is
when you step out of line
then you know you could the way that the
left have devoured their own
i do wonder if that's something that's
going to start happening what is
happening
it's happening and it's not even left to
right it's anything like nowadays
the moment we interview someone whose
views don't align precisely with like
john 73 21 yeah
he's outraged and john 73 he's never
never watching
trigonometry again and it's like well
well then they john 73 21
doesn't have any conviction interviews
right
the truth is when i have people on the
podcast that disagree with me the reason
i'm able
to nod along and listen is because i i
have conviction in what i think i'm not
i'm not challenging if there's something
that makes me challenge what i think i'm
glad about that all right i never
thought about it that way
but i'm not like fundamentally triggered
i mean
that you remember that gif of that girl
you know the triggered guy yeah
you always see that and i always think
about it she could probably tour off
that
the triggered girl i wonder whether that
that that gif is quite old now
yeah she's probably yeah she's probably
she might even be a republican now the
trigger
tricky
girl but yeah that was always like a
trope of the left and it does concern me
that
these guys the last thing these kind of
like hard right guys or
people are really enmeshed in the
culture war would think is that they're
anything like that girl
and yet when you get upset by who's
wearing poppies and who's not wearing
poppies i'd argue you're exactly like
that girl
you know and i would love it if
everybody wanted to respect the
sacrifice that were made in world wars
for this country i'd love it if everyone
just felt like that
but if they don't maybe that's partly
what we were fighting for
was their right to [ __ ] not do that
yeah completely
now we've been in lockdown we've seen
the culture war ramp up what effect do
you think that's going to have on comedy
um well it was interesting wasn't it
because i think last time i was on we
were like
hey man let's just all chill out let's
let's
just do some balloon modelling and and
actually i think the the capacity for
people to just stay at home
and and kind of lose themselves in
online opinions did exacerbate and i
think that there was a period
of you know certainly with the the start
of the statutes opelin
and certain everything seemed to be
everything's more radical every protest
became
more militant and you know the last
summer in particular last summer
um you know there were shows getting
removed from from the bbc and it did
seem i think that that
period again if you want to analyze all
the things that have caused
this uh this vote swing towards
conservatives in england that's all part
of it
of course because people go that's what
the left is you know they want to stop
things they used to be the fun guys i
remember
in the 90s the left was the free speech
thing you know another thing i found
funny recently is is
you'll you'll probably both have had
this it's people online they don't
understand how they sound to a broad
audience of people so often they'll say
yeah he's one of these free speech guys
he's going that sounds all right
he's one of these free speech warriors
sounds like a good warrior yeah why
would being a free speech warrior how
the [ __ ] have we got to the point
where left-wing people think that
identifying people as being a free
speech warrior
is a bad thing but that is one of the
processes and consequences
of descending and burrowing as hard as
you can into an echo chamber and the
first chat we had about echo chambers
echo chambers was after the 2015
election and it does feel like of late
everyone was like no i need to get
outside of my echo chamber
but of late it feels like people go no i
think i need to [ __ ] reinforce
with concrete balustrades and a steel
roof
because they've sort of experimented
with it they've realized that they can't
persuade people
so they've they've kind of hunkered down
and also
we haven't been able to see people face
to face like we might not agree on
everything but we can have a chat and
the human element
is there and we're sort of understanding
that we're both human beings but online
none of that
none of that exists and none of that
happens you're just an avatar to me and
i my job yeah with facts and logic well
that's what i find so often when when
people i had fallen out to people on
twitter then we me in person they go
there's a thing called between us i was
like we fell out on twitter
do you know what i mean that's to me
that's like playing your mate at
playstation you're lobbing the joypad
and just [ __ ]
going for a walk around the block
because you're angry that's the level i
see it as but a lot of people
have made that confusion between that
and real life and even on my lads what's
up group where there was a couple of
political discussions over the last few
days about
brexit and i thought you know what let's
just stop talking about it because
i know that if we had this chat over a
point this would be fine
this would be absolutely nothing like um
the chat that we have now but
i i wonder if people become addicted to
the adrenaline that a good old tear-up
gets
people that feel alive don't they you
know when you know what you oppose you
know what you believe in
people feel a lot a lot of these it's
mainly middle-aged blokes let's do this
here's always middle-aged spokes they
watch question time they drink some
merlot and then
and i think i don't feel like that i'm
not i don't
think and maybe i communicate badly i
don't feel like a combative person but
the problem is is when you know when you
tweet something i'm often
they'll think i'm be i tweeted like this
is a bit funny you know
don't think i'm in a finger jab in [ __ ]
you lefty's way
but that that's not my style and and
maybe that's why i'm i'm really excited
to get back out touring in september
is then that was smooth
keep it touring yeah but but just
because then if someone wants to pull
what you're saying out of context
they'll have to literally invent a mood
that wasn't in the room yeah
you know when you're in it what the
brilliant thing about stand up is it's
very
permissive environment and you say
things and people can see you being a
bit cheeky you know they can see your
body
language then you go all right if you
want to come out of that room and then
pretend
i meant something else then fine but at
least you knew in the moment
uh what i was driving at that's what you
know talking about comedy francis was an
action but that's you know i opened for
you a few times and
that's why i was found about your
approach to comedy even you were even
much less even than me
like you are really trying to see things
from the other person's point of view
so i would be the controversial person
opening for you and then you'd come in
and yeah that sort in a way was probably
more conciliatory than the one that i'm
taking out all right
just completely contradicted my no i
just got
transgenders coming over yes well i've
just got more i think i've got more i
know
i think more now i've wanted to talk
about culture war stuff for a while but
i haven't had the joke so i haven't had
the way of saying it but just recently
there have been a few things that have
occurred to me that i go yeah that's
what i think
it's like i'm genuinely not angered by
anybody having a different sexual
identity
or fitting in someone on this kind of
like rainbow
spectrum i mean it'd be a bold mood if
you were jeff just coming out you know
the gays
[Laughter]
but you know we talk about like
sexuality and gender and having so many
different versions
it just suddenly occurred to me that
masculinity and femininity were already
a spectrum
right we already knew you already had
members of your family that you knew
that
the simple notions of masculinity and
femininity didn't exactly apply to them
you know what i mean so your uncle john
that collected
the porcelain dolls or whatever you go
you knew john like
that it was different for him and you
know you know that [ __ ] kim
kardashian and sue perkins aren't the
same right
so that already existed people are smart
enough to already know so if people want
to have
100 words that's fine it doesn't anger
me
but i also think that it's perhaps uh
a bit there's a bit of presentism about
thinking that
previous generations weren't aware of
those differences
anyway and that's my point is i suppose
the point of the
the new tour in a way is going to be i'm
not angry about this
but i do think some of it's a bit
[ __ ] weird but why
yeah and he's true it's a bit [ __ ]
weird like so
he didn't
it's a bit [ __ ] weird yeah well i
mean right now there's the kind of quote
somebody so if somebody was against you
in that moment this is how the internet
will work
they would think that what i was saying
is it's a bit [ __ ] weird about other
sexualities
if they already think you're a bad
person that is what they would take for
that
when i was talking about the kind of
totality of culture war stuff and
the changing of liberal languages and uh
definitions that's that's a really good
example of how that could work why is it
why is it [ __ ]
why are people who are not exactly like
you [ __ ] weird
yeah and vice versa there'll be john
whoever yeah
i can't believe there's only two genders
well maybe there is but jeff is just
talking he's just having a chat you know
like he's got some jokes about it why
don't you go and listen to him yeah i'm
not i mean the truth is i'm not
angry about anything and and my
counselor would tell you that's one of
the biggest
ones i'm freakishly not angry i would
actually probably be helpful for me if i
could get on and have it out with john
72 31
yeah but where do you think the
landscape is going to change when it
comes to comedy on tv
because the mash has been cancelled
there's a real thirst
for centuries political comedy comedy
that attacks both the left and the right
do you think that
there's going to be a company or tv
company who's bold enough to make that
or do you think we're going to be
playing the same photo as before well i
mean as always i think comedy has
already changed it's a question of
whether tv catches up
so we know that you boys have been
successful in doing this and other
things
andrew doyle's had a best-selling book
simon evans tours leo's done great thing
dominic frisbies
had a hit song you know and if i'm
leaving anybody out it there's just
there's a lot of there's a lot of
evidence that it's already changed so
the only question is
does tv catch up interestingly this last
set of election results i think
the liberal left have been guilty of
thinking well we'll just normal order
will be
resumed soon brexit was just okay bring
the 2019
general but they'll all come back to
labor eventually
normal order will be resumed i think
that these local elections have
underlined
perhaps that there is a more ongoing
change and i don't know if tv companies
can forever ignore
this huge percentage of people and it's
not about i don't want to
be in a right-wing comedy show i don't
think anyone in britain is going you
know what we need
we there are a few people there mainly
online but he's got we need a view we
need it
all the other way that would be a
massive mistake to go from a left-wing
bias to a right-wing bus
but what they do want i think or find it
odd that there doesn't exist
is diversity of opinion so say for
example you're on a topical panel show
and the issue of meghan markle comes up
and say she said something massively
a wildly pretentious is obviously
[ __ ] ridiculous to a lot of people
but you may have people on that panel
that feel because of the culture war
they're uneasy about
criticizing meghan markle a woman of
color who already gets a lot of unfair
scrutiny from the press
so what you end up with is a panel of
people that don't say anything bad about
meghan markle you go well
that's not really where britain's at you
know my own view with with megan and
harry
is again it's not about anger it's just
that i liked him at the beginning and
bit by bit they started to piss me off
yeah and they sort of reminded me of um
you know like a couple you meet on
holiday and you befriend them for like
a day you go oh oh megan and harry like
such a great couple and then
three days later you're like jesus i
cannot take these two you know
that's as simple as it was to me right
it's not a controversial thing to say
but even that opinion you wouldn't
really hear uh within a topical panel
show so i
i have discussions with with people
there are plenty of people in tv
that get this and and again this will be
something that a lot of defunder bbc
type people won't want to hear there's a
lot of people in
very high up in the bbc that get this
but it's a huge machine so there's a bbc
on one hand
you know there's various seniorities of
commissioners
then there's production companies you
know and in fairness to production
companies when they get into tv there's
a kind of tv show that they want to make
and you know the platform in as they
might see it
right-wing views maybe wasn't why they
got into television but the truth is
if terrestrial television doesn't
accommodate these views you know
topical comedy on terrestrial television
is going to
continue to diminish and the worst thing
is it's a very
like if you're pro bbc right it's one of
the easiest sticks to beat the bbc
isn't it yeah it most topical output
would reflect a certain bias however one
show
i know people just think i'm asked
kissing it but i think one show has
proved how well it can work is the news
quiz
andy's ultimate now the the resident
house absolutely brilliant
but it seems in their lineups most weeks
they're having somebody from the other
side of the fence
and i think it helps everybody because
it has certain views represented
and it also for the crucially for the
left-wing comics
it stops them from feeling like part of
the establishment do you know what i
mean
so somebody brilliant like alan cochran
goes on and he makes a joke that
that might make a lot of sense outside
of metropolitan areas but then the
left-wing comet can then
come back on that and it's just more
natural it's so blindingly obvious
that this is what needs to happen but as
you as you guys know the last time this
argument happened there were
people insiders at the bbc that somehow
claimed that
well it just doesn't make as much sense
in london and that's where we record
most of our stuff
but they also said right-wingers aren't
funny there was someone oh there's no
one out there well let me tell you
i give i've been given people a list of
people that i
know and i've said if you ever want to
chat with me after that came out i said
look
these are all the funny people that you
could call upon if you so wished
and the idea that somebody like me
couldn't have a good gig in london
london and people wouldn't believe this
but it's the easiest place for me to
sell tickets by a factor of a billion
people because that's untrue it's not by
a billion
but even when you sort of factor in
population differences
that is you know that's the place where
we're where we do best and even if
even if you just break down the
demographics of london i mean look at
the current london mayoral vote
even the amount of londoners that voted
leave with still
several million people yeah so i think
there is
resistance in certain cause but i think
in the long run
they're not really doing the bbc any
favors actually
because it's one that topical comedy is
one of the easiest sticks to beat the
bbc with and
and you don't need like a whole panel of
people like me
you just need out so there's five people
on the show or seven
one person per show that's that few yeah
i don't think that's too much and the
thing is the thing is if they don't do
it the internet will kill them
it's just as simple as that it's already
doing it you know like we you know my
podcast and
you guys with this the reason that these
things have done all right
is because it's low-hanging fruit and
it's amazing thanks mate
i yes the reason is you're a bit scared
but no one else is here
no but you do it well there's an
audience i know exactly there's an
audience for it you know
i think certain figures have said oh the
reason right wing comedy and i don't
think this is about right-wing comedy by
the way i think it's comedy
that reflects another point of view
perhaps a small c conservative view in
society
it hasn't done well because there's not
a market for it
there is and also you can't say that
when the audience
for legacy topical shows and television
it's just a steady managed decline
right this is so the there's just
literally no evidence to stop
changing comedy on television so let me
ask you just one quick thing on that
uh how did you feel about match being
cancelled well matthew i mean look i
enjoyed it
while i did it and i think that in
fairness to show it gets a lot of stick
from the left
it was and remains the only show to give
somebody anywhere right of center
a regular platform that's true you know
no one has even come close to that
i know a lot of people think i've been
on certain shows and i i haven't
i'm happy for them to think that i have
mash gave a regular
you know and and obviously the tone and
stuff of that show i had to fit in with
the show
um to a point but i was still able to
say things
i was still able to make jokes about jk
rowling gary lineker you know jokes
about second referendum jokes about
jeremy corbyn
i think what it was was when it went
left-wing went very left-wing but he
also had
uh it had jokes from the desk that were
about corbin
and stuff so it did have quite a lot of
balance in it and i look back on the
bits that i did with nish and i think
that
i didn't realize that at the time but
that was something quite unique you know
there were two people
are very different opinions trying to
sort of get along
it was you know it was a challenging
thing to do in terms of getting
a piece that kind of worked together the
audience the audience were good to me by
the way you know they were very
um they were very left-leaning and
remaining but they were fair with me
and one of my best memories of that show
was it was at the time
just before i think it was late 2019
right labour didn't really have a brexit
position
and and they'd come up with this
position which was that they were gonna
uh get a new deal take it to brussels
and then have a referendum on it where
they campaigned against it and i was
trying so hard to write a joke on it
and then i just said that in the room
and then the audience pissed themselves
laughing
and i thought that's a left-wing
remaining audience mainly
and it just underlined that there was a
spirit of fair play in the room so
so yeah it's of course a show that
you're in regularly
it's a it's a shame but then i think if
that show's not going to exist
there needs to either be in existing
shows there needs to be
more of people like us or there needs to
be something new
that picks up that slack do you think it
was a political decision
i might give you a now political answer
um i i think that when a show
doesn't get renewed it wasn't actually
canceled actually there's a slight
difference
it is more than just one thing you know
it is more than just one thing and
jeff don't you think like you see the
fact that these producers
look at declining engagement decline
view
viewership don't really do anything to
change it is it
mirrored by left-wing politicians seeing
declining votes
and again doing seemingly doing nothing
to change it
i do think that
[Laughter]
you know what i've learned this thing
when you're doing interviews you put it
so well
i went to go all i'd have done was say
what you said with different words yeah
yeah i agree
basically yeah and again that is a
problem but
i don't think they're going to change if
i'm being honest because to me
to to me they see it as a moral issue
they see conservatives right of center
as being involved who's they though when
you say they
i i think the people who are on the left
the people who are staunch labor right
you we see them
and again look it's so anecdotal you
look at the social media whatever else
they see the people on the right as
being immoral so there are
there are a constituency of people that
see it that way
but and you're gonna you'll love this
but even with the book that i've got
coming out yeah
but the editor of that book the guy that
commissioned me to make that book the
guy that's invested in that book
is he's very left-wing you know there
are people that do see
that this is not helpful to the left and
maybe i guess what i'm saying francis
maybe
that's where it'll come from they've
realized you know i've got this cycle
i'm such a simple
person right but narcotics cycle is the
right win elections left double down on
culture
yeah right it keeps going like that so
they think [ __ ] you okay you won that
last election i'll tell you what
our tv show is going to be even more
left-wing and working-class people go
well i'm a bit worried about all that i
think this doesn't seem to represent my
experience i think i'll vote tori again
he goes oh vote tori again did you
we'll check out our new tv and this
cycle
check out our adverts right and check
out our stances and it's this ridiculous
kind of merry-go-round
what it really needs is people on the
left to actually go this it's just
good old-fashioned conservative
pragmatism this isn't helping us
we've now had 11 years of this we
haven't really won any major elections
apart from
khan in the last mayor election probably
again this time by a smaller margin
maybe we should do it differently and by
i think the fear maybe was that if we
allow it a voice it will get bigger well
it's got bigger without having a voice
what do you think is going to be the
future of the beep jeff do you reckon
it's going to survive
uh yeah i do i want it to survive i mean
there's a lot of reasons why
right now thumbs down on the video we're
both on record saying we think the bbc
should survive provided it can evolve
with the times
yeah yeah i know i think but there's
lots of reasons i've heard recently
that i think i mean one is like a bbc
music on air like
commercial radio stations their
playlists are a fraction of what the bbc
is right so if you
one thing i love one thing i'm really
patriotic about in this country is our
music culture it's incredible
yeah we absolutely smashed the per
capita
the amount of great songs we've produced
in this country should be a source of
pride for [ __ ] everybody
and part of the reason for that is that
you can get a lot more different music
on when you've got to stay
broadcasted and when you've just got a
commercial broadcaster and i think you
know the investment
uh in comedy and sometimes you know we
did the funeral of prince philip and
the early days of kovid there is a
capacity uh to bring people together
and i think that there are like i say
there are people at the bbc
in very senior positions that do get
this and it's now becoming a fundamental
point is that diversity has to include
diversity of viewpoint it can't
the whole the idea that the output in
media
tv shows and stuff news should reflect
broadly what britain is is a good idea
you know what i mean it's
a [ __ ] logical idea right everyone
should have a place at that table
but it loses credibility if it doesn't
include viewpoint right
that's where a lot of people tap out but
that's not fair you're prioritizing all
other kinds of diversity apart from
people you disagree with so people do
get it
the point is is the culture he's such a
huge employer of how much time
the people that are currently at the top
have and i mean it's like an
oil tanker turning it round keep it's
the same message
again and again we're not changing this
this is this is the new course
and you're gonna have to uh you're gonna
have to get on board and again
it's like this will benefit the left if
people love the bbc
then actually a bit more uh diversity of
viewpoint and also you know
programming from people from working
class backgrounds that's going to help
you
because it's going to help the bbc to
exist longer
jeff listen man it's always great to
chad's good to see you again last time
we recorded an interview
it was literally the day before the
pandemic like properly killed oh there's
a new one coming
yeah there's it's sort of it seems to
have hit the labour party first this
time
uh but there's there's not really a new
pandemic coming you both look to me
what's he talking about what the [ __ ]
has he heard
yeah she didn't check the news this
morning apparently there's a new
pandemic guys
no if the everything's gonna
everything's gonna be fine i i'm a good
you know
that's not part of my politics just
optimism i have a general feeling that
things are going to be
all right we're gonna do okay this is a
great country you know
and that's what allows someone like a
[ __ ] occasional charlotte like boris
johnson to do all right cause that's all
he does
yeah level up great job job jobs jab
jabs
you know i don't often say this but to
to the russian mind
boris johnson being the leader of this
country is inexplicable
it is it's inexplicable it is sweet have
you got this guy
them that's [ __ ] yeah boris johnson
yeah
do you know what i mean i don't think
i've ever you know the most conservative
i ever was i still didn't have
a thing in the window yeah you know what
i mean that person's gone
you know what i'm gonna do you know what
jeff in the interest of balance and this
is what balance looks like we spent 50
minutes bashing the left
we're going to do two minutes at the end
about the tories our official friend who
you've already referred to dominic
frisbee tweeted about this election has
just happened saying
uh the problem with this is it's going
to make the tories think they're doing a
good job
yes i mean that was a brilliant that was
a brilliant point because they they
they haven't on a lot of issues and one
of the biggest issues with the
conservatives is communications have
been dreadful
often dreadful flip-flopping coming out
with really strong stances gavin
williamson
right i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna take
schools to court
oh no actually we're having a lock down
anyway [ __ ] just stand back a bit
mate just fall back until you've
actually got
um a policy they're also quite patrician
and nanny state-ish and the other thing
is boris because
in a way his own vanity needs him to
have younger more impressionable
politicians around him
they did away with a lot of really
experienced politicians javid
case javid penny morden amber rudd
really good
skill people nicki moore people like
nikki morgan have gone so there's a
generation of politicians below them
that just
have been learning on the job at really
difficult time i think one thing is
they have done the hours now it's
probably good to keep them around
because they've done hours and hours
of media media time but like someone
like for conservative somebody like matt
hancock who suddenly
[ __ ] decided he was the nation's
stepdad
has been very difficult to stomach you
know i think when the new variant came
along
everything changed to a point but before
that matt hancock sort of go well
we i'm going to try and let you have
christmas and yeah who [ __ ] gave this
guy
could somebody i mean i'm not advocating
bullying but please just flash his head
down the toilet briefly
because i i there were points last year
i would love to be there but you know
with matt hancock he'd be the guy that
after the third time that happened he'd
learn to love the taste of toilet water
that's how he would power himself like a
sort of super villain
and i know that we've got torrey and p's
that watch this show
look i'm not owned by anyone you know
like and they've been plenty of times
one thing that has been
odd to me is like people have presumed
like oh well
oh you just got on to to kiss the tories
arses no i like critiquing
politics generally i have a bias
definitely you know i have a bias but
over the course of last year if anyone
has listened to my podcast or see me on
on shows i've had plenty to say uh
about the toys and i do think that some
of the cronyism
is something that you know i think
they're quite happy now that it seems to
have died down and the interest has died
off
but once you get out of the context of a
pandemic saying
it felt right at the time it's one of
those arguments in history
there's a lot of stuff that felt right
at the time matt but what i don't want
to see is you and everyone you know
riding around on [ __ ] jet skis
because
you you got rich off a pandemic i
understand they did they made certain
decisions
which needed to be made quickly but that
context will fade away over time
and and maybe that's one glimmer of hope
for the left is we might have a stream
of
look at this guy who bought a place in
in the british virgin islands you might
see people that got very wealthy off a
pandemic and that that might be one of
few routes back for the labor party
well jeff it's been absolutely brilliant
thank you so much for coming on if
people want to find you online where is
the best place to do that
twitter jeff norcott and uh yeah as i
say you'll find i'll be
flogging the show out of the book which
comes out may 13th and then the tour
i blame the parents is uh in september
check both of those out and we're going
to ask jeff a couple of questions for
our local
before we do that jeff our last question
for the main interview itself is always
the same what is the one thing we're
still not talking about that we really
should be
annoyingly when you said that i've
mentioned them already
um in the interview but i do think this
this desertion of the kind of people
that would naturally vote labor to city
centers
i think that that will be where some of
the labor debate goes next there's not
many people talking about that
um right now and then the other thing is
it's something that i've i've just said
just now which is about
tory cronyism i do think that you know
the major government in 92
you know got elected with a reasonable
little majority but over time
sleaze nipped at their heels i think it
is a mistake
to think it's very easy man i've just
said the labour party is going to split
but after the 97
election result tory's finished forever
they'll never come back for this
policy we're all so stuck in the present
now i would be
hate you know i'd be cautious about
thinking that this is now
10 years of boris johnson i mean just
look
just look at boris johnson and saying
could he go 10 years
without doing something that sees him
launched
uh from from office so i think that
maybe the thing that we'll be talking
about
soon is perhaps there's a lot of hype at
the moment about the tories are embedded
for a decade i personally think that one
way or another whether it's through
different coalitions of parties i don't
think it's quite as nailed on as that
i think he's going to carry on doing
just fine with even younger and younger
girlfriends and younger and younger kids
mate
and and the public will just celebrate
yeah exactly he's had his 15th kid well
done boris
yeah yeah well you know there's that
weird thing in a lot of other
democracies when
there are scandals that are supposed to
hurt the politicians yeah but do you
remember who was the one john
hollande the the president of france
like when he had that affair
apparently one of the main things that
lost him points in the polls was the
tacky way that he arrived
through it he arrived on the back of a
moped to his missiles his place
a lot of french people were going that's
outrageous you're going yeah cheating on
his wife they go no no he's on a moped
man
turn up in a [ __ ] limo mate yeah do
it with a bit of class it's france they
have
mate when it comes to these things
anyway jeff thanks for coming back
where i went right is the book and the
tours uh don't blame the parents
i blame the parents not dumbledore it's
where did i go right
and uh we're gonna cut that bit out
don't leave me
where did i where did constantine go
wrong yeah in saying where did i go
right
i don't blame the parents um
it's early maybe if you're a lefty it's
called maybe i need two titles it's
called i don't blame the parents oh that
sounds nice
yeah exactly yeah well make sure you
follow jeff he's one of our favorite
guests ever one of our favorite
comedians
jeff thanks for coming back we're gonna
do a couple of quick questions uh for
locals but in the meantime
thank you for watching we will see you
very soon with another brilliant
interview like this one or a raw show
all of them go at 7pm uk time take care
and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using
the link below